so here's what we know about ufos the
u.s government has verified the real in
the sense there are objects moving in
the sky that we cannot identify
they're certain they do not belong to a
foreign nation they're not from russia
or from china and third we know that
these objects are moving in ways that we
cannot replicate explain or even
understand so everyone who studied this
in the us government will admit that
privately
no one has really said that out loud and
that may change very soon
so for the first time in half a century
there will be a public hearing on ufos
the house intelligence subcommittee will
hear from two senior pentagon officials
tomorrow
on what the defense department actually
knows about these objects the pentagon
and intel agencies are reportedly
feuding tonight on how much the public
should know louis zondo is a man who
does know he's a former pentagon
official who ran this program looking
into these objects he joins us tonight
thanks so much for coming on so
what would possibly be the justification
for holding back from the public what
the u.s government which the public pays
for
knows about these objects
well in fact it might not be so much
what we know tucker but the fact that we
don't know some things uh clearly from a
from a national security perspective the
last thing you want to do is ever
broadcast your if you will your your
intelligence gaps uh to your to your
enemy and in this particular case you
know you said it yourself there's a lot
more we don't know than we do know but
you're right this is a historic move
since since 50 years ago the last time
we were faced with this you had the air
force briefing the results of project
blue book here we are half a century
later and now we have senior dod
officials now not just the air force
coming up and and
providing information to congress and
ultimately the american people
do you know if there have been
conversations between american officials
and their counterparts and say russia
and china over these objects i mean
they're not just spotted around u.s
military installations but also in those
countries and around the world do we
ever talk about this offline
well you know let me give you a real
example there was a very classified
memorandum at some point back in the 60s
that the united states and russia agreed
in writing that we would report to each
other when we were looking at the
northern tier making sure that neither
one of us thought the other was shooting
a nuclear weapon at the other and
there's actually a a small paragraph
that says look if you happen to see a
ufo
do us a favor call us first before you
press the button because
it it may very well be just that a ufo
and not not not us and so i i think um i
think there are certain examples of that
where we had information sharing with
other countries in some cases allied
countries and now even in the law the
law that was just passed recently that
was co if you will sponsored by senator
gillibrand and senator marco rubio where
it says now we are enjoying we must we
have to work with our friends and allies
on this topic it's no longer an option
we have to do it
so you've just you've said you've
answered your questions one the us
government has had full awareness of
this for 60 years this was in the 1960s
you said and second we know for dead
certain these are not
foreign military aircraft
yeah i mean look congress is doing the
right thing by having these hearings and
i'll tell you something else i suspect
there's going to be more hearings after
this this is just establishing the
baseline for congress but we know again
about project blue book we know about
some some efforts beforehand and we know
about my program atip and then after
that we had the uap task force but what
about the 47 years in between what other
efforts did the us government have what
did we learn in that time and is there a
way we can get that information now
under a single tent so we're not in
essence reinventing the wheel we can
compare and contrast information we
learned from before as compared to what
we're learning now with better and and
more more capable equipment this is an
inherently significant story and maybe
that's why it's been written off as the
province of crazy people uh you've
persisted though we appreciate lou
elzano thanks so much for that preview
thank you for having me
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight